et bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver émission largement consacré ce
soir à l'audition didier raoul pendant
trois heures vous l'avez suivi sans
doute en direct sur notre antenne le
professeur star de liège chu de
marseille sous le feu des questions des
députés à l'assemblée hydroxy
chloroquine rôle du comité scientifique
masques et teste tous les sujets qui
fâchent ont été abordés alors que
retenir de cette audition raul qu'est-il
devenu bien plus qu'un médecin on en
parle dans un instant avec nos invités
c'est un duo politique aussi improbable
qu'il a tendu le premier journaliste
engagé à gauche toute
le second patron de plusieurs
entreprises leur point commun ils sont
tous les deux députés l'insoumis
françois ruffin et le marcheur bruno
bonnell font cause commune pour les
métiers du lien de quoi s'agit-il ils
viendront tout à l'heure nous en parler
sur ce plateau en fin de la peinture
rouge aspergé sur le buste et les jambes
et une inscription les groupes phobie
d'état la statue de colbert devant
l'assemblée nationale a été vandalisé
hier soir les principaux responsables
politiques condamnent on fera le point
sur cette polémique mémorielle qui ne
retombe pas voilà donc pour le programme
ces partis attaques sévères n'oubliez
pas on
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
c'était donc l'image du jour on va la
regarder ensemble une forêt de caméras
pour accueillir didier rahout le
professeur marseillais qui vous le voyez
s'est frayé un chemin jusqu'à la salle
lamartine à l'assemblée où se déroulait
cette audition et qui à la demande de la
présidente de la commission denquête a
levé la main et a juré de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité sous peine de
sanctions pénales c'est la tradition il
y a donc pas dérogé on va revenir sur
ces trois heures de questions réponses
avec nos invités à renommer des t-bonds
soir vous êtes spécialiste de la
communication politique rédacteur en
chef de la revue politique et
parlementaire
la forme est importante mais le fonds
compte aussi et peut-être même un peu
plus bonsoir pierre tattevin je sois
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
infectiologues au chu de rennes
président de la société française de
pathologie infectieuse et avec plusieurs
de vos collègues vous venez de de signer
un communiqué qu' au fond vient contre
d'autres de vos collègues d'autres
médecins qui vante les mérites de
l'accord au kiné on attend philippe
berta philippe berta qui a assisté à
cette audition qui est député la
république en marche et généticiens de
profession mais c'est la tradition on
n'y déroge pas dans ça vous regarde on
va commencer par le billet d'humeur de
stéphane blakowski si j'ai bien compris
tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir myriam bonsoir dans notre sens
bon soir myriam bonsoir messieurs si
j'ai bien compris ce soir didier rahout
ces voies déjà bas en tout cas si j'ai
bien compris à myriam on finit par se
demander si le professeur raoul doit pas
devenir un personnage politique qui va
compter dans les années à venir enfin il
ya quand même un élément qui s'opposent
à cette hypothèse c'est le fait que le
professeur out répète à longueur
d'interviews que jamais jamais il ne se
lancera en politique bon moi je dois
faire deux minutes sur le sujet je vais
pas m'arrêter là
donc à vous rappeler quand même que des
gens qui crient haut et fort que jamais
jamais une fronde politique et qui
finissent par y plonger jusqu'au cou
sade et ça c'est déjà vu donc je montre
un magazine que j'ai sorti de ma
collection qui veulent de 90 voyez ces
playboy avait quand une foule a
peut-être connu
donald trump figurez-vous qu'il a
délimité review 90 donald trump où il
disait mr il était catégorique armes il
était sûr à 100% que jamais au grand
jamais il ne se présenterait à
l'élection présidentielle voyez à quoi
vous pensez que si trump a changé d'avis
raout peut aussi changer d'avis par
comme edouard philippe
quand on ne sait pas on doit dire qu'on
ne sait je ne serai pas le sait quand
même que roselyne bachelot a remarqué le
jour que le professeur out avait un peu
le sort est la même personnalité que
donald trump alors le dire pourquoi pas
ce qui est sûr c'est que le problème sa
route en tout cas toutes les qualités
pour faire de la politique et la preuve
c'est que pendant la polémique qui a eu
lieu sur la chloroquine il n'a pas
vraiment réagi comme un scientifique
dans cette politique dans cette
polémique il a plutôt réagi comme un
politique ah bon ce qui me fait dire ça
c'est que ce qui était frappant c'est
que pour prouver qu'il avait raison dans
sa thèse de la chloroquine au lieu de
s'appuyer sur des tests et des
protocoles validés par la communauté
scientifique lui préférer de dire qu'ils
avaient raison
grâce aux sondages alors si ça c'est pas
un truc de politique de s'appuyer sur
les sondages durant le temps de discuter
un peu votre papier parce qu'il a fait
la science a quand même tout à l'heure à
l'état qu'il ait pas fait tjrs ans mais
ce que je vous dis je vous voir le
prouvez moi aussi il s'appuie sur les
sondages ça c'est certain
ce qui pour un scientifique n'a
évidemment aucun intérêt c'est non pas
parce que une opinion majoritaire se
dégage que une vérité apparaît pour
autant c'est pas parce que 75 % des gens
sont persuadés que l'homéopathie et
efficace que ça apporte une preuve
scientifique donc
l'idée même de s'appuyer sur l'opinion
majoritaire c'est pas du tout attribut
scientifique salle a de sens que si on a
une démarche politique parce
qu'effectivement en démocratie c'est
l'opinion majoritaire qui va dicter les
choix politiques donc en bon politique
que tel le professeur out
eh ben ils raffolent des sondages
écoutez le avec votre confrère david
pujadas qui était sur lci vous voulez
faire un sondage ont trouvé moi non mais
vois jouer je suis voilée garantie que
poser des questions
entre vérin et moi pour voir qu'ils
croient voulais voir ce que c'est que la
crédibilité à marseille je suis certain
que vous avez un nouveau record en
france fait fait lui mais son envie
danser les gens se posent la question
fait les sondages donnent raison
professeur draw enfin me disais ça au
mois de mai les sondages 2d février donc
il n'y a pas trop de mal à prévoir le
résultat
oui dans l'élite figurent sur le podium
donc doxa des trois personnalités les
plus appréciées des français en ce
moment faut relativiser un petit peu en
marc rapp c'est quand même trois
nouveaux venus qui sont tous deux du
domaine médical que jérôme salle au
moins sur le podium alors qu'il a quand
même y'a pas un charisme de folie non
plus et que finalement out avait quand
même des regards roselyne bachelot qui
est encore plus populaire que lui
n'empêche ça confiant comme un soufflé
que ce qui confirme quand même que out a
un profil très très politique c'est
qu'il est très clivant dans ce domaine
quand on demande aux français quelle est
leur opinion sur la pleurote la
chloroquine et bien savary uniquement en
fonction ou en principalement en
fonction de leur opinion politique donc
je vais regarder encore une fois sont
des loyers la chloroquine ces
manifestants un médicament d'opposition
puisque les filles 3 81% et rennes et à
l'air aussi beaucoup en revanche si on
est plutôt du côté macro en marche et
ben on y croit beaucoup moins donc on se
demande parfois mais souvent d'ailleurs
quelle est la personnalité qui pourrait
un peu fédérer ce mouvement déchiré
jaune qui part dans tous les sens
au fait qui a eu francis lalanne qui a
essayé bon pas marché jean marie bigard
a l'air d'y croire pour 2022 mais le
professeur raoul lui à un vrai profil
puisque c'est vraiment un critère
déterminant les gens qui se sentent
proches de gilet jaune font beaucoup
plus confiance aux professeurs out que
basso qui n'y croient pas le professeur
à haut risque d'être dans la course pour
vous en 2022 je suis le trafic pendant
la course mais ils risquent en tout cas
des publicités ça me paraît évident
qu'on va lui demander
on va tenter de le rallier vous avez
remarqué que à la fois jean luc
mélenchon et et marine le pen ont tous
les deux pris sa défense en disant qu il
trouvait que ils avaient raison que
c'était intéressant donc la prochaine
fois qu'on verra le professeur raoul à
l'assemblée à vous de pardon se sait pas
forcément en commission il sera ministre
de la santé il viendra s'exprimer devant
l'hémicycle face aux députés mais bon
pour ça il faudrait que en 2022 ce soit
soit le pen soit mélenchon qui soit élu
et là c'est pas encore joué donc il ya
beaucoup de choses dans ce papier merci
merci stéphane on va évidemment plonger
dans ce qui s'est dit pendant trois
heures par d'izia route par l'est par
les députés mais quand même forcément
une réaction d'art dont une bd leti il
est lieu dit le répète je suis très
heureux de faire mon métier je vous
rassure disait-il tout à l'heure devant
les députés je n'ai absolument pas envie
de faire le vôtre
on peut le croire c'est un scientifique
c'est un scientifique indéniablement son
parcours parle pour lui au-delà
aujourd'hui de l'objet médiatique qu'il
est devenu à la faveur de cette crise
qui était une crise hors norme cette
crise sanitaire qui l'a mis sous les
feux de la rampe
mais avant tout sa carrière jusqu'à
maintenant c'est celle d'un scientifique
qui publie dans des revues scientifiques
qui sont de très grandes revues qui est
un des chercheurs les plus cités dans
ces revues qui a reçu le grand prix de
l'inserm et qui est dans les canons
académiques de la recherche
sauf que cet iconoclaste mais oui il est
iconoclaste si vous voulez parce que et
on l'a vu lors de cette audition c'est
quelqu'un qui remet en question le
fonctionnement institutionnel du système
de la recherche vous avez noté quand
même qu'il y à deux organismes qui ont
été particulièrement critiquées
durant cette audition sont des
organismes qu'il connaît très bien qui
est l'institut pasteur l'autre
l'institut national de la santé pour la
santé et la recherche médicale
donc c'est quelqu'un l'inserm c'est
quelqu'un qui considère aujourd'hui que
le fonctionnement institutionnel de la
recherche n'est plus adapté enfin en
tout cas n'est pas adaptée à ses yeux
donc en effet il un positionnement
politique sur des questions qui relèvent
de politiques publiques de recherche
nationaux alors on va l'écouter quand
même bon parce que vous allez continuer
l'analyse dans un instant
pour tous ceux qui n'auraient pas suivi
cette audition en direct les temps forts
compilées par maïté vraiment je vous
invite donc à lever la main droite et
dire je le jure je jure confinement le
masse dans la rue ces décisions
politiques
il n'y a pas de données scientifiques
qui permettront jamais prouvé ça parce
que c'est des notion d'écosystème qui a
été déchargée sur des scientifiques et
des décisions médicales qui ont été
préemptés par le politique et sur lequel
là je suis vraiment désaccord donc je
crois qu'il ya une vraie réflexion à
savoir quelle est la part du politique
quelle est la part du médecin etc est la
part de scientifiques je ne suis pas
d'accord avec la décision qui a été
prise de ne pas généraliser les tests et
c'est moi qui ai expliqué excuses au
président pour la première fois et qui
lui ai redit vous savez la pcr c'est
très simple et tout le monde peut faire
et donc c'est pendant tout ce temps on
n'a pas dit la vérité il a été tenté de
faire une vraie évaluation de l'hydro de
cycle rockin avec la citron piscine mais
la mise en place de sa a été tardive et
que donc le test mais il n'y a aucune
évaluation décès du tout qui a été mis
en place par son conseil scientifique
c'est une faillite totale
rien du tout rien et il y arrivera
peut-être quelque chose mais quand il y
aura plus de 15 donc ça devrait vous
faire réfléchir sur le degré
d'efficacité
si vous voulez de ce type de stratégie
j'ai pensé
peut-être que je me trompe mais si vous
voulez c'est surtout à moi-même que je
rendais compte donc je vais essayer
d'avoir les cimes de moi-même de d'être
en accord avec moi-même
c'est ce que j'essaie de faire donc j'ai
pensé que je pouvais être utile dans
cette liste parce que je crois que j'ai
une expérience qui est extrême dans ce
domaine là et j'ai essayé de le faire à
chaque fois comme je pouvais bon il se
trouve que dans ce conseil scientifique
j'ai été un ovni donc le moment où un
extraterrestre donc et pas de
compatibilité génétique entre douch
n'était pas possible il faut arrêter de
se regarder le nombril arrêter toute
cette histoire c'est parce que les gens
ici sont crus ils pas qu'ici en europe
de l'ouest les gens sont crus plus
malins ils ont des mauvaises habitudes
si il y à une épidémie de coronavirus
actuellement en nouvelle zélande qui
débute on peut se dire mon dieu est bien
possible que nous en ont reprenions
elles deviennent saisonnière l'année
prochaine pendant la saison froide et je
salue l'arrivée de philippe berta
bonsoir vous êtes donc ici parce que à
peu de retard parce que vous venez
d'assister à cette longue audition
vous avez réussi à l'énerver vous êtes
le seul qui a hérité du doigt sur la
table c'était pas du tout mon objectif
en lui posant une question sur des
études thérapeutique on va y venir vous
êtes député modem du gard et généticiens
de profession quel est votre sentiment
général à l'issue de cette audition
est ce que vous avez appris des choses
d'abord je souhaiterais que sa clôture
ont une longue histoire maintenant parce
que c'est un peu fatiguant quand on est
tout à la fois député scientifique de
recevoir toute la journée dès soit des
injures soin d eux parce que c'est
devenu est vraiment ça est vraiment
catalyse est quelque chose d'assez
bizarre dans ce pays moi je suis bien
sûr parce qu'il ya des moment donné où
je joue je demande en tant que
scientifique des des faits des faits
scientifiques avérées a testé en marche
comme ça dans la science avec le
jugement des pairs puisque c'est comme
ça aussi qu'on fonctionne on peut
effectivement se marginaliser plus
accepter le système fazia teneur des
comptes calais même temps ça voilà bon
et moi le problème que j'ai derrière ça
je vous le dis c'est pas le problème de
la chloroquine pas la chloroquine moi je
ne demande qu'à le croire je veux
simplement voir les effets je veux qu'il
soit à tester et que l'efficacité soit
démontré qu'elle est le seul 3ème
sortant jeu mais je en tout cas je ne
veux pas que ce soit l'image qu'ils
soient donnés de ma communauté
ceux qui souffrent aujourd'hui je peux
vous le dire pour discuter avec beaucoup
d'entre eux c'est cet épisode
aujourd'hui ne correspond pas du tout au
monde scientifique
alors là vous aurez le monde y est en
creux sur la communauté scientifique et
la communauté médicale que vous
représentez absolument je les écoute et
vous pourriez mettre sur sur cet homme
là pendant sept ans c'est un homme
brillant on l'a connu son connaissons
pas ses scientifiques sur les risques et
si on connaît on connaît son parcours
c'est un homme brillant mais c'est un
homme aussi qui manifestement cessé
manipuler son monde
enfin là il a été remarquable moi j'ai
je vais pratiquement jamais entendu de
de vraies réponses de vraies réponses
aux questions il est toujours parti dont
il ne répondait pas auquel ont répondu
réellement question enfin lille peut il
pas difficile de me répondre par exemple
sur le
même des tests pcr et chacun sait et
tout le monde le sait que les tests pcr
le problème c'est que c'est pas la
panacée
parce qu'on voit on a des fois jusqu'à
50% de faux négatifs
donc même en testant toute la population
ont valu saleh généraliser les tests
oui la chair à marseille on va rester
général on rentrera dans les sujets les
tests la chloroquine après je me tourne
vers vous que vous clôturez pour la pour
la forme
en général comment vous l'avez trouvée
est ce que vous avez appris des choses
il était différent de ce qu'il est ce
qu'il est d'habitude face à des
journalistes disons qu'il est très
confiant c'était oui mais justement pas
par rapport aux journalistes oui des
plus agressifs plus cash
là il m'a semblé plus plus précis plus
calme il est très confiant ce qui lui
donne une communication qui a été très
efficace mais je pense que c'est un des
problèmes c'est que il a eu son instinct
initiale de penser que l'hydroxyde
l'euro qui ne serait le traitement
miracle et finalement trois mois plus
tard alors qu'il ya eu beaucoup d'études
dans d'autres pays fait par des gens qui
eux n'avaient pas de d'apriori qui
disent que ce n'est pas efficace
il va il va rester sur cette ligne là et
comme il est fort et comme il est
intelligent et comme il présente bien
les choses
ça risque d'être bloqué encore quelques
temps alors heureusement la france c'est
pas tout le monde et tous les autres
pays du monde probablement vont petit à
petit abandonné les roxy chloroquine
mais au risque d'être un peu en retard
nature
arnaud benedetti sur la forme sur la
forme il est excellent moi je pense que
c'est la meilleure prestation qu'il a
réalisé depuis trois mois en
l'occurrence manifestement ils l'avaient
préparé il était moins agressif que lors
parfois de face à face avec un certain
nombre de journalistes et il a montré
une amplitude qui fait qu' il a
indéniablement percé l'écran lors de
cette audition
mais si vous voulez moi l'eau je suis
pas tout à fait d'accord avec vous la
communauté scientifique c'est une
communauté qui est profondément fracturé
par des controverses
l'histoire de la science c'est une
histoire de controverse et parfois de
confie très violents entre des écoles
entre des chapelles entre entre des
hommes qui ne sont pas d'accord sur un
certain nombre de principes
méthodologiques et qu'elles soient mis
au grand jour est forcément pourquoi les
maisons
mais non elle est en général elle n'est
pas mise au ban de la communication
scientifique elle reste à l'intérieur de
l'enceinte académique
c'est le débat vous l'avez rappelé le
débat entre pairs c'est à dire qu'on
s'évaluent entre soi on discute on se
dispute la dispute et parfois violente
il ne faut pas croire que le monde de la
recherche est pas un monde qui est un
monde très douce et un monde avec des
rapports de force des rapports de force
entre institutions des rapports de force
entre icônes sur qu'est ce que ça change
randy ce qui est nouveau pourquoi ces
deux pourquoi c'est apparu aujourd'hui
au bonjour tout simplement parce que
vous avez eu une crise qui était
inquiète une crise telle sur le plan
politique une crise sanitaire qui est
devenue une crise politique et donc qui
est devenue une crise médiatique et vous
avez un certain nombre de personnalités
qui sont apparues au grand jour et qui
ont fait valoir leur position de manière
très forte
qu'est ce qu'a fait raul en fait un
outil la balle passer d'une certaine
manière les les canons de la
communication 100 courts circuits
traditionnels il les a court circuité
pardon excusez moi pour mettre au grand
jour
en effet un certain nombre de thèses
qu'il considère comme lui des thèses
tout à fait scientifiquement valable
mais voilà moi c'est pas à moi d'en
juger
et il a mis ça sur la place publique et
donc en effet il est apparu comme en
plus il ya un autre aspect avec raul si
vous voulez dans un moment où on a eu le
sentiment qu'il y avait un grand
désarroi dans le pays jetant d'yquem aux
gens de se confiner de rester chez eux
c'est le tout ça là où tous aux abris
il arrive avec une parole forte qui est
une parole ou il dit moi j'ai des
solutions
quand tout le monde doute quand toute la
communauté quand le politique ne sait
plus comment agir
vous avez quelqu'un qui surgit et qui
vient vous dire moi j'ai des solutions
je garde mon sang froid et je vous dis
voilà comment il faut faire et donc en
effet il a une communication qui de ce
point du live et qui a été une
communication extrêmement efficace et en
plus quand même
l'arrêté on l'a déjà dit mais il a son
parcours scientifique antérieures qui
parlent pour lui il a été grand prix
inserm et encore ça c'est quelqu'un qui
est quand même dans l'académie qu il est
il et il a une position intermédiaire si
vous voulez il est très fidèle à votre
avis pourquoi il prend quelque part
l'opinion à témoin il cherche quoi parce
qu'après tout s'il veut convaincre et
perd il peut le faire dans le huis clos
de la commission
il faut jamais oublier que rajouter
quelqu'un qui par exemple publier des
billets dans le point
bien avant qu'on connaisse didier raoul
comme on le connaît aujourd'hui
c'est quelqu'un qui a toujours eu une
forme d'api
tance quand même s'ils voulaient ce
n'est pas un chercheur qui est seulement
spécialisée dans sa spécialité il fait
partie encore une fois d'une figure du
chercheur qui n'existe plus tout à fait
aujourd'hui qui est une figure du savant
qui considère que parce qu'ils les
savants il peut avoir une parole
autorisée sur de nombreux sujets raul a
publié de nombreux livres qui ne sont
pas automatiquement des livres qui
relèvent de son domaine de compétence
c'est quelqu'un qui a des avis qui a des
opinions qui les expliquent ils à ces
politiques l'un des effets de ses prises
de position c'est justement la notorité
que ça lui a donné aujourd'hui je
voulais montrer ce schisme et 98 % des
françaises savent où disent qu'ils
savent que cette la chloroquine le taux
de notoriété de raoult il est incroyable
et d'état de ministres au gouvernement
qui n'ont pas sa notoriété il serait
construit
c'est comme ça en maintenant c'est
officiel sûr c'est très bien comme ça
chaîne youtube avait au maximum 1000 us
sur certains programmes
maintenant il ya des films qui dépassent
le million de vues comme par hasard il
un bouquin qui fort en ce moment donc je
mets une crise ça n'a rien à voir qui
n'est pas du tout intéressé mais moi ça
me paraît surtout très bien organisée
sur sa communication alors on va essayer
de prendre les sujets les uns après les
autres parce que on voit quand même
aller bertha je crois que le vrai termes
qui qualifient didier rahout et c'est un
collègue infectiologues qu'il connaît
bien puisque finalement je suis dans une
commune ligne qui n'est pas très loin de
marseille un peu dans le monde de
réflexologie moi je décris comme un
explorateur c'est important c'est
intéressant d'avoir des explorateurs
c'est à dire des gens effectivement
qu'ils sont peu marginaux par rapport à
la façon stratégie a toujours été un peu
la même quand on regarde son parcours il
va jeter une information
et puis il attend deux solutions
l'information était pas la bonne et 2 le
résultat n'était pas un n'a pas été
effectivement dupliquer personne ne l'a
reproduit
c'est pas grave il sait que ça soupire
assez rapidement et il a bien raison
parce que l'on sait comment les choses
vont vite
deuxième solution ah on démontre qu'il a
raison il a été le premier il a toujours
fonctionné un petit peu comme ça c'est
une femme et je vous les reconnaissez
quand même le statut de scientifique
oui oui sur la montée l'impression que
seul nom
ça donne pas le sentiment que cela
durera où la scientifique
on peut pas la maison operandi façon
d'opérer qui sont pas les nôtres
bon il suffit de regarder avec un ballon
d'essai repas l'éthique voilà il faut
regarder sa disqualification sa liste de
publications
je pense qu'il est le seul au monde à
voir une mise aux publications aussi
l'ongle mais en soi c'est suspect ça
veut dire est vraiment très long
laboratoire publie plus que puisque le
cnrs qu'il son 3000e il sens voilà donc
il ya une gamme et il y avait quand on
le qualifiait à l'époque ont souvent
j'entendais dire assez celui qui publie
plus de publications qui a deux jours
dans l'année et je crois que c'était pas
tout les tous les ans faut aller aux wc
ça veut dire qu'ils ont complété cette
image elle est effectivement plutôt
plutôt favorable c'est bien vu des gens
jouent là on arrivé là
une épidémie un virus qu'on connaît pas
de proposer des choses qui étaient pas
que pas connu et le proposer comme un
traitement c'est une bonne chose
ce qu'il faut pouvoir dans ces cas là
pour que ce soit bénéfique et que ce
soit pas dangereux pour les patients
c'est être capable après quand on
connaît mieux l'épidémie qu'on connaît
mieux le virus qu'on a eu le temps
d'évaluer de dire ben finalement c'est
mon intuition n'était pas la bonne et je
pense qu'il va falloir qu'on arrive à ce
alors justement japon avant de conclure
s'il vous plaît je vous redonne la
parole juste après pour ceux qui nous
regardent vraiment on essaye de faire un
point claire sur l'idh roxy chloroquine
avec avec vous géraldine parce que
passer avec nous ira dès le 29 bonsoir
j'espère que vous êtes en sort avec nous
derrière votre écran
est-ce que vous pouvez nous démêler un
petit peu le le vrai du faux ou est-ce
qu'on en est puisqu'il ya eu des mea
culpa de revues scientifiques comme on
en est de la recherche aujourd'hui et
des études sur cette molécule
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que le
consensus aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
en tout cas est clair aucune étude n'a
prouvé l'efficacité du traitement
proposé par le professeur raoult
contrairement d'ailleurs à ce qu'il a
dit pour la représentation nationale
pas même ses propres études et il y en a
eu alors que certaines bien fait de plus
fragile des plus solides ont porté sur
de larges cohortes et leurs résultats
coïncident l'étude recovery en grande
bretagne plus de 1500 patients initiée
fin mars
elle a été arrêtée parce qu'on
n'observait pas d'effet bénéfique ni sur
la mortalité à 28 jours ni sur la durée
de présence à l'hôpital autres vastes
essais conduits par l' oms solidarité
pas non plus d'effets là enayat
américaine a elle aussi jeter l éponge
de son essai conduit sur 500 patients ça
marche pas alors les inconditionnels du
professeur raoul vont vous dire c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas donné les bonnes
doses pas au bon stade de la maladie
mais on a aussi eu d'autres études
conduites au stade préventif en espagne
dans le minnesota notamment on a donné
le traitement à 3000 personnes qui
avaient été en contact rapproché avec le
virus elles sont tombées malades
exactement comme les autres la plus
récente étude et je vous en parle parce
qu'elles datent d'il ya quelques jours
elle a porté sur des patients des
hôpitaux de l'ap-hp
elle ne montre pas non plus des effets
du traitement sur la mortalité mais les
patients qui ont reçu hydroxy
chloroquine tout seul semble avoir guéri
un petit peu plus vite que les autres
ils sont sortis plus vite de l'hôpital
en revanche ceux qui ont su l'hydroxyde
chloroquine associé à l'asie premier
film cet antibiotique que donne le
professeur à vous ceux là ont un risque
de mortalité légèrement accrue donc en
clair les sociétés savantes aujourd'hui
dans le monde entier considère que ce
traitement non n'a pas fait ses preuves
ça devrait vous réjouir merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup géraldine c'est
exactement ce que vous ce que vous
écrivez dans votre communiqué en tout
cas ce que vous dénoncez tout ce qui
serait au fond les avocats de la
chloroquine effectivement les sociétés
savantes jusqu'ici où on attendait de
savoir la vérité on trouvait que c'était
un petit peu péremptoire la
communication sous hydroxyque l'euro qui
met en avait pas les réponses maintenant
qu'on a les réponses quand la semaine
dernière on a entendu sur d'autres
chaînes qu' on aurait pu éviter 25 mille
morts si on avait donné deux lignes
hydroxy chloroquine à tout le monde
s'aide pas dire à hourtin qu'il ait dit
non non c'était le professeur peron de
garches ses sympathisants
là on s'est vraiment dit qu'il fallait
qu'il fallait parler d'abord parce que
c'est fou il faudrait pas à si on
n'espère pas qui aura deuxième vague
mais il ya une deuxième vague forêt par
refaire les mêmes erreurs et redonner
roxy chloroquine aux gens et puis
deuxièmement on est en train là d'aller
mieux après une épidémie qui a été
difficile où tout le monde a bien tiré
la langue
et si vous allez annoncer aux gens que
parmi les gens qui ont perdu du monde
pendant cette épidémie que ça aurait pu
être évité si on avait eu le bon
traitement
c'est vraiment très très délétère non
seulement c'est pas vrai mais ça fait
beaucoup de mal et c'est pour ça qu'on a
écrit cette tribune et que ont vraiment
rien en même temps était soir et elle
mais en même temps philippe berta il
n'est pas présent sur ce plateau avocats
tant de ses soutiens à redire à août
excusez moi c'est un c'est un praticien
en temps de crise et il le dit lui même
quand on est dans dans la crise
sanitaire
on n'a pas le temps de faire des études
thérapeutique c'est trop long il faut
traiter soigner et ce médicament je vais
reprendre ces chiffres il a été déjà
distribués à 36 millions d'exemplaires
donc moi je sais ce que vous répondez à
cet argument largement l'argument
inverse c'est que alors monsieur c'est
pas un argument je ne suis pas
cliniciens je ne suis pas infectiologues
je ne suis pas vers le rouge
finalement je parle libéré mais en tout
cas j'ai écouté puisque j'ai auditionné
pendant mon confinement c'était ma
sucette extraordinaire je vais passer
dans mon temps dans ma chambre dans le
cadre de la mission que je présidais sur
la recherche locaux vides tous les tous
les plus grands en france les sansonetti
les phisheurs j'ai bon j'ai quand même
entendu quand même un niveau de
raisonnement qui moi me pose question
quand même c'est que effectivement on
avait des essais cliniques
1 ceux qui ont été cousus par reacting
sous l'égide de l'inserm et caetera et
j'ai eu quand même beaucoup de collègues
qui m'ont dit de notre problème c'est
qu'on ne peut pas inclure de patients
dans les essais cliniques qui donc viser
pas uniquement la glisse toxiques lors
qu'il n'y avait pas de molécule en test
des antiviraux des anti mollahs des anti
hiv et c'est pourquoi pas parce que les
gens pour la plupart s'étaient déjà auto
médicale et au roxy chloroquine donc on
n'a pas pu mener des tests comme on les
aurait souhaité d'autres molécules c'est
pas censé qu'on ne pouvait plus les
inclure dans un test sur une 2e année
ont déjà pris une donc ça me manifester
ça pose ces résultats s a manifestement
mis dans les études ont mis tellement de
temps à être fait c'est aussi à la
tester en tout cas je l'entends du de la
voix de de deux collègues et et puis
effectivement qu'en tire aujourd'hui la
difficulté c'est qu'il ya plus assez de
passion pour inclure donc c'est pour ça
que cette deuxième vague dont on parle
on la craint parce que on a on n'a pas
grand chose de plus en main pour
l'affronter si c'étaient nos gestes
barrières et notre stratégie confinement
qui date de plusieurs siècles et c'est
ennuyeux c'est ennuyeux maintenant il ya
les sports l'accident le mail dans
l'opinion a renommé dts que c'est
compréhensible cet argument au fond les
études thérapeutique alors dans leur
majorité montre à ce stade que c'est
inefficaces voire dangereux en cas de co
vide et en même temps il ya un
professeur qui à marseille un bilan
comment comment on se positionne quand
on n'est pas médecin par rapport j'ai
aucun avis sur la question du traitement
en l'occurrence je suis comme n'importe
quel françaises et français j'écoute les
arguments des uns et des autres et c'est
aujourd'hui extrêmement difficile de se
faire un avis tri fondée sur cette
controverse parce que les ya une espèce
de d'argumentation et de contes
argumentation des uns et des autres et
rien n'est démontré par contre la
réalité
ce dont on s'est aperçu c'est que le
temps de la recherche
c'est un temps qui est long et le temps
la recherche ce n'était pas un temps
adapté indéniablement la démarche
scientifique même n'était pas adaptée à
la réalité de la crise que nous
traversions la crise que nous
traversions l'opinion publique et les
politiques d'ailleurs également demandé
des réponses qu'ils étaient des réponses
rapides des réponses qui permettait
finalement de trouver des solutions à
l'épreuve
l'épreuve épidémique à laquelle ont été
confrontés sauf que la scientifique
il peux pas vous répondre de manière
référendaire à une question ne peux pas
vous dire c'est oui ou c'est non c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué ce virus
on le connaît pas ou on le connaît mal
on en connaît mal les propriétés on le
connaît mal la vitesse de propagation de
circulation donc les réponses que
pouvaient faire les scientifiques et les
chercheurs aux politiques
ben c'était des réponses hypothétique
des réponses avec du doute et si vous
voulez le problème des essais cliniques
les essais cliniques randomisés maigrir
pour arriver à un résultat il faut du
temps il faut plus de 18 mois
donc c'est des essais qui sont thème
assez lourd expliquez-nous ses deux
essais avec un groupe placebo
c'est un seul essai mais si on veut être
sûr que la différence entre deux groupes
soit vraiment lié au traitement qu'ils
aient reçu il faut qu'ils aient été
tirés au sort donc ce qui a été fait
dans des essais comme recovery par
exemple c'est que les patients
recevaient donc on est tirés au sort
pour avoir un traitement ou un autre ou
pas de traitement et qu'au bout de
quelques semaines on arrive à savoir
dans quel bras les les gens vont le
mieux mais ça fait pas dix huit mois
alors on commence à voir des résultats
très sérieux qui peuvent déjà nous dire
ce qui ne fonctionne justement c'est sur
cette question-là des sectes vous l'avez
raté géraldine juste pour la dernière
fois il ya des essais cliniques dont ton
considère olic qui ont été des échecs je
pense que discovery je dire en
l'occurrence à poser un problème
la vaste enquête européenne c'est un
problème européen donc on est on est sur
un autre type de problème ce que
j'ajouterai sur les essais c'est qu'il
faut aussi savoir que c'est pas le
médecin qui soigne qui donne du
traitement lui c'est parce qu'ils
donnent c'est vraiment totalement au
hasard c'est à dire que il donne des
cachets avec un numéro dessus mais toute
l'analyse derrière qui va être effectué
sur votre essai c'est certainement pas
le praticien qu'il pratique c'est bien
une structure annexe où l'endurance et
une sculpture de l' oms pour discovery
qui récupère ses résultats et qui
ensuite les décortique ses propres tests
de lui
c'est en somme c'est en effet en trois
jours vous contestez ses méthodes
géraldine justement quel est le bilan
d'hier à août à marseille mais c'est et
ce qui est un problématique il a encore
cité devant des députés ce soir l'étude
monstrueuse qui l'aurait fait à
marseille sur plus de 3500 patients
cette étude n'a toujours pas été publiés
dont je n'ai pas pu la lire mais dans la
précédente étude qui portait sur 1000
patients mais c'est frappant didier
raoult a marseille il a testé tout le
monde donc ses patients ils ont 44 ans
de moyenne d'âge alors qu'on sait que
les malades ou en général plutôt 60 50
il a très peu de co morbidité chez ces
patientes par exemple - 2 6 % sont
obèses alors que la prévalence de
l'obésité en france ses 17%
donc ils sont jeunes ils sont plutôt
bonne santé et finalement les taux de
cas graves et de létalité qui
l'observent sont les mêmes que dans la
population générale 0 75 % de décès
parmi ces patients se selon le m s le
taux de décès global il est de 0 53%
pour le coc vite donc qu'est ce qu'on
peut en déduire
bah rien on ne sait pas du tout si c'est
son traitement qui a été efficace ou si
ce sont des gens qui aurait guéri tout
seul et c'est ce que ces critiques des
reproches depuis le premier jour et ce
qui fait dire aux scientifiques
on ne sait pas merci géraldine bon on va
passer à une autre un autre sujet un
autre thème je pense qu'on a fait le
tour sur cette question de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine il a attaqué dur ce soir et
c'est peut-être la nouveauté sur la
question des conflits d'intérêts il a
attaqué notamment une partie du comité
scientifique et plus largement tous ceux
qui étaient au fond contre lui en disant
qu'on n'avait pas prescrit la colline
roxy chloroquine parce que certains
laboratoires
il n'a pas cité de nom pratiques liées
mais certains laboratoires
pharmaceutiques au fond avaient intérêt
donnait de l'argent qu'est-ce que vous
répondez là dessus moi je suis trop mal
placé pour répondre parce que je suis un
peu loin de tout ça j'ai passé de
directeur de recherche à l'inserm et je
suis toujours professeur diversité mais
je suis un peu loin de la pression
honnêtement j'espère y faire l'industrie
femmes à main
très sincèrement en tout cas moi je
parle de thé scientifique que je connais
et j'en connais beaucoup et j'en
fréquente beaucoup et je continue à
fréquenter
vraiment on est à des années lumière de
cette réalité là que les scientifiques
bien sûr un moment donné de leur
carrière en fonction des thématiques et
un contrat de recherche payés par
l'industrie pour financer une partie de
leurs recherches
je pense que ça bien sûr évidemment et
j'imagine que allié je suis de marseille
c'est pareil et heureusement il avait
ses obligations de sanofi avec bien sûr
le bien sûr donc on a besoin de cette
contribution du privé à la recherche
publique
honnêtement
moi je n'ai jamais connu je ne connais
pas et et c'est pas parce que je ferme
les yeux c'est franchement la méthode
populiste en se demandant bien mon
obsession que c'est un personnage
politique il a vraiment les attitudes
politiques bas de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les populistes qui est rude
les journalistes comme fonds mélenchon
le pen
ils critiquent pas en permanence
l'establishment qui exactement la même
attitude qu'on le pen et non qu'il est
surimposé un positionnement qui se
rappelle d'ailleurs dans ses soutiens
qui sont les électeurs les deux extrêmes
mais il faut quand même savoir que raul
tu dans sa relation avec les grands
organismes de recherche a toujours eu
une relation assez conflictuelle ça
c'est pas nouveau on le découvre
aujourd'hui encore il faut à la faveur
de cette crise toute la carrière de raul
tu sais quand même bâti pour ceux qui
connaissent un peu l'histoire du monde
de la recherche contre les institutions
de recherche et d'ailleurs c'est la
raison pour laquelle il a créé son nid à
chu il a bénéficié d' ailleurs du
soutien des organismes de recherche ou à
l'invitation du chu en appel d'offres
c'est bien oui on prend donc c'est
l'état qui paye c'est l'état qui paye
mais je veux dire c'est avoir une
indépendance par rapport aux grands
organismes de recherche dont il
considère qu'aujourd'hui ils ne font pas
son travail en tout cas c'est ce qu'il a
laissé entendre encore dans cette danse
est dans cette audition moi j'ai pas sûr
qu'ils soient populiste le problème
c'est que bien évidemment il apparaît
populiste parce que il a une position si
vous voulez extrêmement iconoclaste dans
le monde institutionnel de la recherche
donc et c'est ce qui fait en fait si
vous voulez c'est l'art est une des
raisons pour laquelle il a une adhésion
d'opinion parce que finalement il vient
d élite mais on venant des élites
il s'adresse le dis clairement il est
assez sûr de ceux de ce qu'il est et de
ce qu'ils représentent ça tout le monde
s'en est aperçu parquet la verrière qui
est la vérité c'est que il a un langage
et il a une communication et là je vous
rejoins qui est une communication qui
finalement est assez audible pour la
majeure partie de l'opinion publique
parce qu'il parle avec des mots qui sont
des à l'opinion publique
vous voyez rarement et scientifique
s'exprimer comme didier rahout et didier
rahout il a cette force cette force de
communication
cette force de persuasion qui ont fait
alors en plus encore une fois dans un
moment qui est tout un moment tout à
fait particulier un personnage clé
dernière dernière côté d'éléments allez
je pense qu'il ya vraiment un mot
elle qui qui peut vraiment être bien
illustrer la situation
l'épidémie de sida y en a parlé pendant
plus prendre plusieurs reprises à la fin
là c'est vraiment une maladie qu'on a
réussi maintenant qu'on contrôle bien il
ya plus du tout le même pronostic qu'au
début et ça ça a été avec les
collaborations entre l'industrie
pharmaceutique et les médecins qui
voyait les patients donc c'est comme ça
a été dit des partenariats pour que les
patients puissent bénéficier des
traitements le plus vite possible et que
l'industrie pharmaceutique puisse
évaluer les traitements pour savoir
lesquels marche bien et contrairement à
ce qu'il a dit à plusieurs reprises à la
fin de cette audition la quand il dit
pour le sida on n'avait pas besoin
d'essais randomisés on aurait pu juste
mesure et la charge virale et on aurait
fait autant de progrès c'est absolument
faux ça les premiers traitements ont été
essayés dans le sida avant qu'on fasse
des essais randomisés étaient des
catastrophes et c'était si on avait
appliqué la méthode round pour le sida
je pense qu'on aurait encore une survie
à trois ans parce qu'on ne pouvait pas
se dire tiens ce traitement là il a
l'air de bien marcher je vais le donner
à tout le monde et je vais pas le
comparer avec le reste on n'aurait
jamais réussi à contrôler l'épidémie de
sida si on avait appliqué ce genre de
méthode donc il faut faire des études
randomisées et il faut travailler avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique et vous
l'avait bien dit d'ailleurs au
professeur raout on n'a pas le temps de
vous repassez l'extrait parce qu'à alex
taylor qui nous attend notre chroniqueur
franco-britannique bonsoir alex alors
est ce qu'on parle beaucoup de la
polémique autour de didier raoul tu en
grande bretagne
non mais je peux vous proposer une
polémique maison infiniment politique
hier ont pris fin les conférences de
presse de 17h des five o'clock on
envoyait toujours ministre parfois même
johnson himself accompagné d'un
représentant du comité dix sages faizi
groupe fall emma jones --le groupe de
conseil scientifique en cas d'urgence
acronyme on ne peut plus parfait donc
mais dont les membres tenait plus en
plus à se distancier c'est le cas de le
dire avec ce qui était annoncé juste à
côté envoyé à par exemple que le
responsable scientifique tenue toujours
à une distanciation public entre les
gens de 2 m contrairement à ce
qu'annonce et par les stones sun qui
prônait un plus énigmatique un mètre
plus haut qu'à il s'agit des gestes
barrières c'est médical vous nous avez
parlé de bisbilles politiques
eh bien le vous ce round ce comité la
composition devenait de plus en plus
opaque surtout concernant la
participation du cerveau derrière
dominique commun ce grand prêtre de
l'immunité du groupe
jusqu'au jour où il tombe à lui même
malade et c'était plus en plus
d'habitants que les responsables
scientifiques étaient gênés devoir
défendre sa politique en public
si bien qu'il ya moi s'est formé un
comité sage alternatif qui contrairement
à celui du gouvernement a fait ces
réunions grand jour suzume sur youtube
pour que tout le monde puisse voir et
ils n'étaient pas d'accord c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire sous plusieurs
éléments clés de la politique on s'en
moque qu'ovide notamment sur les mesures
au temps des ehpad sont ouvertes sur des
écoles et des frontières tout temps si
je peux finir là-dessus mais rien sur
une petite notions grammaticales
anglaise johnson a toujours dit oui
following the signs nous suivons la
science aux on aurait pu dire en anglais
mais forains suns
nous suivons la science de manière
générale mais la foi d'articles
sous-entendait qu'il n'y avait qu'une
seule voie scientifique possible article
ou pas arctique
dentiste de questionner la sacra région
est souvent celui de la mort ou la merci
merci à alex on voit bien que la grande
bretagne n'est pas épargné par des
politiques à la fois médical est très
très politique vous aurez le mot de la
fin
liberta franchement didier raoul tu n'as
pas tout raté produits voulu
reconnaissez sa personne testée
non mais parce qu'il ya eu quand même
voilà il n'est pas les représenter en
tant que soutien sur ce plateau vous les
reconnaissez d'avoir testé notamment à
marseille là où les tests n'étaient pas
forcément disponibles ce que j'aurais
sauté sur le fond
j'aurais voulu conclure par sas je pense
que c'est le rêve de tout à chacun c'est
que il est raison et qu'il hydroxy
chloroquine fonctionne moi je pense que
c'était notre souhait commun oui mais je
ne connais pas leader moult je connais
de nom pas plus c'était mon souhait donc
après sur les tests moi je le problème
c'est qu'ils me répondent pas non plus
aujourd'hui un test pcr est en fait qu
rt pcr tel qu'il annonce c'est quoi le
nombre de faux négatifs et un faux
négatifs remy j'allais dire dans la vie
courante mais rapidement très dangereux
aujourd'hui à part le test sérologique
les tests en tout cas pcr telles qu'il
les pratiques qui les a pratiqué et qui
continue à se pratiquer c'est une
indication mais c'est pas une indication
d'une rigueur extrême loin s'en faut
qu'avez-vous après pour terminer
rapidement à ce stade de la commission
denquête alors moi je vais vous faire un
aveu je débarque dans la commission j'ai
quelques sujets d'abord professionnels
électoraux cette semaine voilà donc j'ai
effectivement assisté à didier houssin
c'est quand on est effectivement toute
la problématique des masques moi je
pense qu'il ya quelque chose qui s'est
pas dit que j'aimerais préciser parce qu
on allait y venir on a parlé de société
allemande de sociétés dans le dans ce
qui manque dans ce pays fin je dis ça je
les écris d'ailleurs je crois même que
je vais faire une tribune là-dessus
rentrer dans un laboratoire qu'il soit
laboratoires hospitaliers à laboratoires
de recherche et je vous propose juste de
faire un seul bilan trouvez moi un
équipement un petit équipement un outil
de fonctionnement du laboratoire une
enzyme un produit made in france
bahia n'a pas donc le pourquoi à mon
sens de la non systématisation de la pcr
est aussi là c'est qu'en fait après bien
sûr de fournisseurs principaux étaient
en allemagne et les allemands abandonnés
on dit attendez nous on voit d'abord
testé notre population et vos bons de
commande on les gérera l'occasion n'ont
pas vraiment des chantiers bien sûr à
venir notamment du président de
république merci infiniment d'être venu
débriefer cette longue audition du
professeur didier raoult et on va parler
à présent d'un attelage un attelage pour
le moins détonnant l'insoumis françois
ruffin et le marcheur bruno beau
elles se sont entendues pour défendre un
projet de loi commun sur les métiers du
lien de quoi s'agit-il ils vont nous
rejoindre dans un instant mais d'abord
marion mec becker fait le point pour
nous sur tous ses métiers souvent très
féminin qui se sont révélées si
indispensable pendant la crise elles
sont assistance maternelle aide à
domicile accompagnatrice d'enfants en
situation de handicap
elles ont décidé de se battre aux côtés
de françois ruffin et bruno bonnell pour
être enfin reconnu sabrina isabelle sont
auxiliaires de vie sociale à dieppe y en
a qui nous prennent encore pour des
femmes de ménage c'est leur bonne à tout
faire et où aller avec les
verticalisateur l'élève malades fin on
travaille comme à l'hôpital mais elles
n'ont pas le statut des auxiliaires de
vie des ehpad ou des hôpitaux
reconnaissance de notre métier et
valorisation reconnaissent nos diplômes
parce qu'on a passé des diplômes alors
qu'ils sont considérés comme une fille
qui a pas de diplôme elle est considérée
comme nous a fait le même travail le
même salaire hayat
elle est à es h elle accompagne à
l'école deux enfants en situation de
handicap mais c'est pas un métier
malheureusement nous on le considère
comme un métier mais malheureusement
c'est une fonction pour l'instant et
nous on se bat pour avoir cette
reconnaissance du métier moi c'est
franchement 834 euros exactement
voilà pour 24 heures et encore 1 g entre
guillemets la chance d'être
d'avoir trois enfants du coup j'ai
complément familial sinon je serai à 734
euros
hayat est toujours en cdd elle a signé
pour trois ans un besoin de
reconnaissance est essentielle pour les
acteurs du secteur
dominique villa et directeur d'une
structure dead à domicile on a placé
depuis des années le secteur de l'aide à
domicile dans un dans un marché avec
toutes toutes les vocations libéral que
peut présenter un marché ça probablement
davantage
ça a amené normes inconvénient c'est que
la reconnaissance de service public de
ces métiers là comme à l'hôpital public
cache finalement à un moment donné le
fait que ben s'il ya pas de moyen âge ou
rien et donc finalement ça passe
derrière françois rue faille bruno
bonnell propose de créer un service
public de ces métiers du lien sans pour
autant les fonctionnarisé ainsi il
serait reconnu et pourrait être mieux
rémunérés l'autre enjeu c'est de mieux
prendre en compte leur temps de travail
un député insoumis un député de la
majorité
un tandem atypique elle les deux hommes
espèrent faire de leur mission une
proposition demeure bonsoir françois rey
femmes bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes député la france 1 sont 10 de
la somme est bienvenu avoue bruno
bonnell ce soir vous êtes député la
république en marche du rhône c'est vrai
qu'on l'entend depuis ce matin tous vous
oppose mais voilà c'est pas juste une
formule tout vous oppose au delà même de
votre parti qu'est ce qui fait que deux
députés
un chef d'entreprise un journaliste
réalisateur engagé très à gauche se
retrouvaient travaillent ensemble qui
choisit qui nous a pas laissé le choix
non mais de toute façon va je veux dire
d'abord que le truc trans partisan moi
ça c'est quand même pas la première fois
que je fais sur les contrats de foule
j'avais travaillé avec michel gym keller
de l'udi sur les aveux sache déjà avec
aurélien pradié des républicains donc
sur des points précis il n'y a pas de
difficulté à les franchir des frontières
et par ailleurs il ya quelque chose chez
bruno bonnell qui le motive dans son
parcours personnel
au delà de des convictions moi c'est les
convictions qui m'anime c'est sûr et
bruno en plus donc des convictions
habité par des tas de rencontres dans
mon cas mais bruno il a une histoire
personnelle qui est lié à ça et qui fait
que sans doute ça fait bouger les
curseurs chez lui histoire personnelle
que j'ai eu un garçon était dans doc est
handicapé donc que j'ai vécu j'ai vécu
ce parcours en fait de ces personnes qui
accompagnent les enfants en situation de
handicap et et forcément je suis
sensibilisé à samé mais par rapport à
votre question initiale le plus
important c'est parce que françois
ruffin et bruno bonnell vont s'entendre
autour d'un de quelque chose d'ailleurs
qui a fait l'unanimité quand on l'a
présenté à la commission économique dont
il y avait pas de cas pas de débat
l'important c'est s'intéresser à ces
personnes qui sont actuellement dans une
situation de précarité de
non-reconnaissance de métier dessous
rémunération qui est proprement on peut
dire le mot scandale qui n'a rien à voir
ni avec la majorité ni avec l'opposition
qui va bien au delà qui a à voir avec
évidemment le niveau de rémunération et
les conditions de travail qu'est ce que
ça veut dire métiers du lien parce que
ça recoupe beaucoup de choses c'est quoi
les métiers du lien les métiers bien on
en a choisi quatre on pourrait
considérer que journaliste est un métier
du lien ou député construit au quotidien
aussi maintenant ce qu'on a choisi on a
choisi quatre métiers ses assistantes
maternelles animatrice du périscolaire
accompagnantes d'enfants en situation de
handicap et auxiliaires de vie sociale
c'est à dire ça va du berceau jusque
avant la tombe quoi et j'ai mis ces
métiers au féminin et c'est pas hasard
c'est à dire qu'à 80%
ce sont des métiers occupés par des
femmes il y avait qu à tout un très
faible revenu et un très faible statut
des femmes à votre alors je pense que
pendant des siècles raisonnement
inconscient de la société c pendant des
siècles ce boulot là il était peu par
les femmes au foyer s'occuper des
enfants des bébés des personnes âgées et
des personnes malades
maintenant le fond
à l'extérieur on les paye un peu c'est
déjà pas mal vont pas nous emmerder avec
ça je pense que le raisonnement dans
l'inconscient collectif et qui fait
qu'on sort pas de ça donc c'est
maintenant voilà c'est l'heure de sortir
mais internet développe un espèce de on
a dit c'est de l'instinct maternel et ce
ne sont pas des métiers cdc des
fonctions cd job c'est ce qu'on veut
mais ce sont ils ce n'est pas reconnue
comme une des professions
alors que la première chose qui nous a
choqués quand on a commencé à
auditionner ces personnes que va
commencer à travailler qui avait valu
est pas une cinquantaine d'auditions
ensemble de aussi bien de deux personnes
qui étaient en activité dans ces métiers
là des syndicats des organisations
professionnelles qui les encadrent des
entreprises qui les gère
et vous avez constaté qu'elle quel grand
invariants manque de considération
salaires trop bas jure donc il ya
l'amplitude horaire qui pour moi est un
problème parce qu'en fait ce sont pour
la plupart de ses métiers des temps très
complet on dit que ce sont des temps
partiels non ce sont des tentes et
complet je prends le cas de martin qui
simplement a commencé ce matin à 8
heures du matin elle a fait auxiliaire
de vie sociale est passé chez trois
personnes âgées trois fois une demi
heure elle a une grande pause
elle a fait un petit boulon l'après-midi
pour servir les repas et elle a eu à
nouveau une grande pause elle va aller
fermer les volets le soir dans ce qui
fait qu'elle va travailler de 8h à 21h
ça va être occupé par son métier mais en
vérité il va dire que des petits bouts
de payer à l'intérieur de ça c'est un
peu la même situation que pour les
femmes de ménage gagnant par quelque
chose qui est des communs et donc on va
avoir une très grande amplitude horaire
avec en revanche des salaires qui sont
très partiels martin alors qu'elle fait
le samedi aussi et qu'elle fait deux
week-ends sur 3 de dimanche sur trois
elle va se retrouver à 800 euros à la
fin du mois et ça grosso modo de
recommencer
comment comment expliquer et sont sous
payés s'est aussi payé l'addition alors
c'est parce que c'est du temps partiel
c'est surtout très mal organisé serre
que ça a été pensé en théorie hanté
l'horizon totalement les métiers seront
lundi
on est descendu à une époque jusqu'au
quart d'heure sert qu'on avait un quart
d'heure pour réveiller quelqu'un et
partir chez quelqu'un d'autre ou on
avait une demi heure pour lui faire la
toilette et puis après et là on a on a
on a considéré que le seul temps payable
c'était le temps effectif c'est comme si
vous vous réveillez al-hanak table on
vous paye et juste pour le temps vous
êtes à l'antenne et tout le travail de
réparation vous avez fait tout le
travail que vous avez fait en échangeant
réflexion essaiera n'existe pas là c'est
pareil c'est le moment où elle est en
activité on la paye sinon tout le reste
temps de trajet temps de transfert tant
d'attentes en des changes avec ses
collègues pour passer les consignes
parce que ces personnes-là eu des fois
on besoin qu'on passe les consignes à
une infirmière d'un ce matin je n'ai pas
senti ou savez attention il était pas
bien ce matin et vous devriez faire
attention quand vous lutterez de sa
piqûre ou des choses comme ça eh bien ce
n'est pas compté dans leur travail
alors c'est des métiers qui sont plutôt
mal payés surtout parce que vous l'avez
bien expliqué il ya du temps partiel et
une journée très haché c'est des métiers
qui sont aussi très pénible et ça on
n'en parle pas oui ça c'est une surprise
parce que je savais beaucoup de choses
sur ces métiers là moi ça fait des
années et des années comme journaliste
que je travaille sur ces questions là
donc là j'étais heureux de l'amener à
l'assemblée nationale mais en effet se
dire qu'il ya deux fois plus d'accidents
dans ce métier là que dans le bâtiment
qui est pourtant l'un chez un ami
oui que dans le bâtiment deux fois plus
nombreux oui donc voilà ça veut dire que
en fait on on discute avec toutes les
auxiliaires de vie sociale et elle
termine avec les épaules broyer les bras
broyer les genoux boyet face il ya des
problèmes au niveau de toutes les
articulations
ça veut dire qu'en jeu souvent ce qu'on
entend c'est qu'on termine en inaptitude
on est évacuée du métier parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à aller jusqu'au bout de sa
carrière à force de porter légende
donc voilà et donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut construire autre chose nous c'est
la construction du statut que les
revenus vont être lié à un moment un
statut qu'on reconnaît une qualification
que ça veut dire un statut commun à tous
ces métiers du soin de l'aide
eh ben vous voyez par exemple comprend
les une accompagnante enfants d'enfants
en situation de handicap aujourd'hui
elle rentre sans avoir eu de formation
particulière il va peut-être y avoir un
petit bout de formation à l'intérieur
nous on n'est pas pour relever la
barrière à l'entrée pareil sur les les
animatrices c'est juste un bafa qui
suffit pour devenir animatrice
périscolaire
on n'est pas pour relever les barrières
à l'entrée en revanche on pense que dès
qu'on est dans le métier il faut avoir
une formation qualifiante et des
carrières et ça forcément pour les
autres
nous on vous souhaite le rapprochement
avec le métier d'aide-soignante et
surtout leurs points d'abord on
considère que les frontières elles sont
ténues entre les deux parce qu'on dit
l'auxiliaire de vie sociale enfin qui
ont en fin de compte elles pratiquent
souvent du chemin tout cas un certain
nombre de soins qui sont donnés à la
personne d'une part et d'autre part on
pense que l'organisation elle doit être
plutôt qu'aller sur ce qui se passe pour
les aides soignants c'est à dire que les
aides soignantes elles ont une tournée à
faire dans leur matinée elles
choisissent un petit peu bon bah je vais
commencer par celui là puis je vais
aller voir celui là après puis celui là
si vous avez organisé voilà aujourd'hui
je sens qu'elle a besoin d'un peu plus
de temps et tout ça alors que pour les
auxiliaires de vie sociale
c'est comme ci comme ça pas de
qualification forte et bien on va pas
avoir confiance en elle dit du coup il
faut quelques badges elles vont à passer
un coup et parce que la réalité c'est
qu'elle badge par exemple elle
rothschild bell ont un téléphone
portable spécial elles rendent chez
quelqu'un et elle elle pose sa sur une
espèce de petite borne qui dit ça y est
top chrono le quart d'heure est parti ou
la demi heure est parti j'ai le temps
d'y aller au foncier thé aux entreprises
pour signaler leur présence pour qu'on
comptabilise effectivement le temps
passé chez la personne est donc en fait
on l'est on les robots teese ont fait le
contraire de ce qu'on devrait faire au
lieu d'en en faire des humains
responsables en disant ok vous avez
votre tournée et si monsieur machin ce
matin il faut rester un peu plus
longtemps
là vous rattraperez votre temps avec
madame truc parce que c'est comme ça non
là c'est un quart d'heure une demi-heure
donc vous êtes d'accord sur les
solutions vous avez un projet de loi
commun donc un statut commun qui se
rapprocherait de celle on est d'accord
vraiment sûr sur les solutions
c'est-à-dire les la reconnaissance la
formation une meilleure rémunération et
une carrière ça je pensais c'est vrai
après on a évidemment dans la vision de
société que nous avons tous les deux on
peut on peut analyser décortiquer des
divergences sur par exemple on n'a pas
mis qu'on devait fonctionnarisé ces
métiers ça devait pas des métiers alors
qu'on pense tous les deux moi je parle
d'utilité sociale françois parle plutôt
de service public
on pense tous les deux que c'est quelque
chose qui doit devenir maintenant du
domaine du national du régalien la santé
devient le grand enjeu du 21e siècle le
soin prendre soin c'est quelque chose de
pivot comme l'a été au 19ème l'éducation
donc ça veut dire que l'on veut l'idée
je crois que notre travail là où il est
intéressant été reconnu ce matin par la
commission des affaires économiques à
l'unanimité parce qu'on a dit on va pas
mettre sur la table ce qui nous cause
qui nous sépare on va mettre ces accords
les points de convergence et c'est pour
ça qu'on arrive à cette idée de deux
propositions proposition de loi qui qui
du coup va on va en parler maintenant
parce que tout commence mais on va
l'accélérer on n'a pas envie que ça
traîne et encore et que ça attendent
encore leur mandat et là dessus on n'est
pas d'accord sur la finalité parce qu'on
a un petit pari est quoi non m je suis
sceptique je veux dire c'est au pied du
mur qu'on voit le maçon et le masson le
en marche on les attend toujours sur le
terrain social depuis depuis trois ans
les personnes qui ont été les personnes
âgées les aides à domicile des ehpad
forcément au coeur des attentes du
président public et les français
regardent déjà la prime kobe ne sont pas
sûrs de l'avoir donc déjà mais donc ça
c'est la première chose mon cellule
c'est le premier signe mais c'est vrai
que nous moi il ya déjà des marqueurs
parce que après nous on a un gros paquet
de propositions mais il ya des marqueurs
sur les accompagnantes d'enfants en
situation de handicap dans les écoles
c'est simple là c'est le ministère de
l'éducation nationale
donc c'est un minimum des cdi et pas des
contrats de un an de 3 ans avec de la
précarité qui dure parce qu'il ya des
solutions
là on est d'accord là dessus et ça sera
un marqueur je veux dire je - vous savez
si le gouvernement il prend 10% de ce
qu'on a mis jeu content je cherche pas à
avoir la totalité
ça sera déjà un pas après on est
d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut en finir
avec le statut de mandataire je suis
désolé si vous permettez chez un petit
et un peu technique et c'est la fin de
cette interview réalisée pour je sais
pas s'il faut terminer là dessus mais à
ça qu'ils m'ont salariés les gens
grosbois l'âge où il faut pas qu'ils
souhaitent on peut plus accepter que des
personnes âgées ou les personnes qui
sont en situation de handicap qui est
qu'ils peuvent souffrir un certain
nombre de déficits soient supposés être
les employeurs des personnes âgées
donc l'avenir le rendez vous est pris
l'avenir de cette mission d'information
c'est médias c'est une proposition de
loi qu'on va co signé qu'on va pousser
auprès de nos collègues pour réussir
j'espère à faire bouger certaines lignes
mais maintenant
un continent invisible moi je pense que
on s'inscrit là moi je m'inscris mon
travail et cette mission dans un truc
dans la durée sa jeu j'espère qu'à
l'automne y aura des trucs qui vont
aboutir et on verra bien mais ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que c'est comme un
continent invisible qu'il s'agit
maintenant de rendre visible il faut
faire surgir le continent invisible et
c'est pour ça qu'on moi j'ai tenu à ce
que ça soit pas un métier mais contre
montre bien leur chiper tel belle et
qu'il ya une cohérence avec eux c'est
normal qu'elles sont devenues ces femmes
dans la crise du coup vide donc
saisissons ce moment merci vous restez
avec nous j'aimerais bien votre avis sur
ce qui s'est passé
vous allez voir ça va peut-être vous
intéressez bruno bonnell me donnera son
avis si vous ne voulez pas le faire ce
qui s'est passé devant l'assemblée hier
avec la statue de colbert aspergée de
peinture rouge avec cette inscription
négrophobie d'état c'est thomas des
prêts qui va nous rappeler les faits et
les réactions ça s'est bien passé
hier soir n'est ce pas thomas oui
exactement myriam cela faisait plusieurs
jours que la statue de colbert était
protégé par des policiers par crainte
d'une dégradation et bien cette
dégradation elle a eu lieu hier soir
je vous raconte tout ça retour alors
c'était l'autre image de la journée
cette statue recouverte de peinture
rouge et d'une inscription en lettres
capitales négrophobie d'état un acte
politique revendiquée par l'association
brigade anti négrophobie l'ancien
ministre de louis xiv est pris pour
cible depuis plusieurs jours comme étant
l'instigateur du code noir un texte
légiférant l'esclavagé dans les colonies
françaises le tag a été vite effacées ce
matin il ne reste plus rien mais le
débat est là faut-il déboulonner la
statue de colbert devant l'assemblée les
députés ont leur avis sur la question
très franchement cette volonté de
déboulonner les statues de débaptiser
les rues ça n'a absolument aucun sens
peut émettre des idées par rapport au
parcours de colbert mais le débaptiser
sur traille faute est une faute grave à
mon sens quand je vois ce genre de
d'actes je pense à ce discours de victor
hugo dieu offre l'afrique aux européens
est-ce qu'il faut déboulonner
est ce qu'il faut des baptisés les
statuts les rues les places qui porte le
nom de victor hugo un des plus grands
républicains
non mais on est devenus dingues c'est à
dire que comme je le dis l'histoire
c'est pas fait pour la réécrire elle
existe elle est comme ça c'est fait pour
enseigner à prendre et ne par corey par
commettre les mêmes erreurs que par le
boss je suis pas pour à les déboulonner
les statues je crois pas que ce soit la
voie apprend en revanche je me sens du
côté en tout cas de celles et ceux qui
aujourd'hui est bien parfois en des
actions jugées choquantes
il ya une forme quelque part peut-être
de provocation nécessaire à l'assemblée
nationale aussi une salle porte le nom
de colbert et certains voudraient la
rebaptiser c'est le cas de l'ancien
premier ministre jean-marc ayrault il a
longtemps été députée ici président du
groupe socialiste
ils demandent qu'on change le nom de
cette salle il a publié une tribune dans
le journal le monde ce week-end et ce
matin sur bfm tv le président de
l'assemblée nationale richard ferrand
lui a répondu la salle colbert sera
t-elle débaptiser à l'assemblée
nationale moi je ne proposerai pas se
soigner
vous savez réécrire l'histoire vouloir
nier une partie de l'histoire vouloir
nier la complexité de l'oeuvre des
hommes c'est quelque chose qui était
absurde moi je crois que au fond il faut
peut-être mieux expliquer les ombres et
les lumières de chaque personnage de
notre histoire
peut-être que là nous avons des efforts
à faire voilà meriane depuis la mort de
georges floyd le sujet est donc à
nouveau sur le tapis mais nul doute
qu'on aura l'occasion d'en reparler dans
ma journée à l'assemblée
merci thomas prenable vous vous
condamner cet acte de vandalisme devant
l'assemblée nationale la statue de
colbert où vous comprenez dans le conte
est au delà de condamner cet acte
effectivement de vandalisme profondément
à mon avis inutile parce qu'il choque
personne mise à part les gens qui l'ont
fait je crois que plus profondément que
ça si richard ferrand qui a raison
débattons discutons argumentant sur
l'histoire n'ayons pas peur de notre
histoire
regardons là avec toutes ces ombres il
l'a dit et ses lumières
non mais c'est pas une question de la
réécrire c'est une question de
l'histoire c'est l'histoire ça fait
partie justement de nos racines et pour
avoir des ailes efficace il faut les
connaître dans toutes les
tous leurs recoins donc moi je suis
plutôt pour pour rester sur ces balises
que nous avons tous temps les discutant
et sans les remettre en question perdant
est certainement pensant jonglant on
mélange en histoire et actualité ce qui
est le cas aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il veut ya déjà d'autres
strates eu à mettre aussi
moi je mettrais louis degrés par exemple
qui est un révolutionnaire qui en 1794 à
porter la lutte contre l'esclavagé en
guadeloupe et qui était un voile a
révolutionné celle là alors on la garde
non mais moi je dis franchement je lui
ai déjà dit je suis pas pour déboulonner
les statues mais par contre les choix
rassurer écrit tout le temps là je suis
pas d'accord l'histoire elle est faite
pour être réécrite
parce que telle qu'elle est écrite
aujourd'hui ce sont les dominants qu'ils
écrivent donc de toutes façons il faut
intégrer à l'histoire
les noirs il faut intégrer à l'histoire
les étrangers faut aller intégré à
l'histoire les femmes
est-ce qu'on est en fait en train de
faire avec notre mission métiers des
liens c'est de vouloir intégrer aussi
des gens à notre histoire à noter enfin
que les journalistes se révise tout le
temps elle serait écrit elle se serait
analyse en intégrant des acquis et le
fait que y'a des gens fassent ça eh ben
ça pose une question en obligeant d'en
parler ce soir donc au moins ça permette
de ça permet de poser des questions en
débat public -si à vous deux très belles
soirées eyadema
[Musique]